[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka
guten abend zum ende seiner amtszeit hat
der noch geschäftsführende
bundesgesundheitsminister kein
glückliches händchen erst presto jens
spahn vor bei der beendigung der
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
sehr zum missfallen seiner cdu kollegen
in den bundesländern
und dann die chaotische kommunikation
über impfstofflieferungen in einer
situation in der man jede irritation von
bevölkerung und ärzteschaft vermeiden
sollte um das wieder einzufangen trat
sparen heute mit zwei der top experten
in sachen impfstoff vor die
hauptstadtpresse bei der gelegenheit
formulierte er auch noch mal was auch
biologen immer wieder erklären wer sich
gegen eine impfung entscheidet
entscheidet sich zugleich für die
infektion aus berlin patrizia wiedemeier
es sind worte die man selten in dieser
schärfe gehört hat worte des
geschäftsführenden gesundheitsministers
heute morgen wahrscheinlich wird am ende
dieses winters
so ziemlich jeder in deutschland
das feld wurde er manchmal schon etwas
zynisch genannt geimpft gewesen oder
gestorben sein die infektionszahlen sind
so hoch wie nie zuvor erneut plädiert
jens spahn sich impfen zu lassen mit
bayon tag oder mit moderner noch am
wochenende hatte sein ministerium
angekündigt dass die auslieferung des
beliebten biontech impfstoffes
rationiert werde weil die lager leer
seien stattdessen mehr moderner verimpft
werden solle die folge heftige kritik
große verunsicherung heute nun der
versuch einer schadensbegrenzung
moderner ist ein guter sicherer und sehr
wirksamer impfstoff manche impfenden
ärzte sagen bei uns ist der mercedes
unter den impfstoffen und moderner ist
der rolls royce dessen beides
hervorragende impfstoffe die für die
booster impfung gleich gut funktionieren
insgesamt sei genügend impfstoff für
alle da versucht sparen zu beruhigen
erntet aus münchen aber heftige kritik
kommunikation am wochenende war
desaströs
das hat völlig falsche eindrücke
vermittelt allein das wort rationierung
hat dazu geführt dass die leute sagen
gerade jetzt wo posten notwendig ist
scheint kein impfstoff da zu sein
schlechte kommunikation einer
geschäftsführenden regierung die nicht
mehr lange im amt ist keine
kommunikation derjenigen die bald im amt
sind irgendwie will in diesen tagen
keiner so richtig verantwortlich seien
auch nicht beim zweiten viel
diskutierten thema eine allgemeine
impfpflicht eine entscheidung darüber
gibt es jetzt nicht und sie würde auch
von dieser bundesregierung nicht mehr
gefällt die nächste regierung sie wird
es entscheiden müssen vielleicht schon
bald doch von einigkeit der künftigen
ampel parteien beim thema impfpflicht
keine spur namhafte experten halten eine
allgemeine impfpflicht für
verfassungswidrig wie auch diese
diskussionen verunsichert die menschen
und spaltet die gesellschaft wir
brauchen aber genau was anderes nämlich
eine gemeinsame kraftanstrengung damit
sich mehr menschen impfen lassen testen
lassen und booster wir als spd
bundestagsfraktion halten das für
richtig eine einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht für sensible bereich
einzuführen das bedeutet seniorenheime
pflegebereiche aber auch die diskussion
über kitas und schulen zu führen dass es
eine debatte die zeitnahe jetzt
entschieden werden muss die gesundheits
minister und ministerinnen die sich am
nachmittag in münchen trafen gehen da
deutlich weiter ihr vorsitzender fordert
eine allgemeine impfpflicht sie wird uns
letztendlich helfen aus der
endlosschleife diese pandemie
rauszukommen und ich denke es auch
richtig dass wir über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht reden nicht nur über eine
berufsgruppenspezifischen sondern eine
allgemeine am abend dann fordern auch
der bayerische und baden
württembergische ministerpräsident in
einem gastbeitrag in der faz eine
allgemeine impfpflicht dies wäre der weg
um am schnellsten aus der krise zu
kommen und die freiheit aller zu
schützen
und darüber wollen wir mit baden
württembergs ministerpräsident sprechen
guten abend herr kretschmann guten abend
herr schlug sie und markus söder
sprechen sich deutlich für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht aus nun wissen
sie auch die kritiker und gegner nicht
nur von der fdp sagen das wäre
verfassungswidrig
das glaube ich nun mal nicht wir hatten
ja ganz lange eine impfpflicht in
deutschland die ist ja erst vor einigen
jahrzehnten aufgehoben worden also das
gab es schon
die wir haben das bei den maßen wenn
auch in abgeschwächter form also das
glaube ich nun mal nicht dass das
verfassungswidrig ist
argumentiert werden das sei nicht
verhältnismäßig oder das würde die
unversehrtheit beeinträchtigen die auch
vom grundgesetz
gewährleistet ist ja ich meine das ist
eben der schwierigen abwägungsprozess
sich deswegen steckt man ja auch erstmal
etwas zurück ist ja ein tiefer eingriff
in das persönlichkeitsrecht
aber wir müssen ja sehen die wir
bekommen ja nirgendwo auf der welt diese
pandemien richtig in den griff wenn wir
zu niedrige impfquote haben das heißt
die ganzen beschwernisse die wir dadurch
haben aber auch überlastete
intensivstationen wo dann zum schluss
entschieden werden muss wer wird
behandelt und wer nicht das sind ja noch
tiefere eingriffe in die lebens rechte
von vielen tausend menschen nicht
insofern ist es ein abwägungsprozess und
wir glauben dass wir damit die freiheit
der gesellschaften dessen schützen und
sie nicht behindern muss man ja auch
dazu sagen impfpflicht es mich im zwang
also wenn jetzt nicht die leute von der
polizei zu hause abgeholt und zum arzt
geschleppt sondern es ist eine
verpflichtung wenn man dagegen verstößt
bekommt man eine strafe wie stellen sie
sich das vor wie das umgesetzt sondern
wie man es auch kontrolliert ja gut
darüber müssen wir uns dann den kopf
zerbrechen wenn wir soweit sind jetzt
haben ja erst mal nur eine debatte
eröffnet und argumentiert was sind die
argumente die dafür sprechen jetzt
werden sicher andere kommen und auch die
argumente dem entgegensetzen die dagegen
sprechen und dann werden wir uns wenn
darüber ein konsens zustande käme
darüber auseinandersetzen wie sieht es
dann aus sicher wird niemand im
gefängnis landen und sich erholen wir
niemand mit der polizei zum impfen ab
sondern bußgelder gehen und es wird
natürlich um die einschränkung gehen die
heute schon jeder mit 2g erlebt nicht so
muss man sich das vorstellen
wir können davon ausgehen dass unsere
bevölkerung sich in der regel an solche
gesetze auch hält und das dann macht
auch wenn sie sich selber im einzel
vielleicht nicht davon überzeugt sind
dass könnte und es trotzdem ziemlich ein
sturm entfachen also gerade im
baden-württembergischen starkem
skeptiker bewegung auch total an ihrer
partei mit gruppierungen die
anthroposophischen weltbilder nahestehen
homöopathischen weltbildern und die sehr
skeptisch traditionell skeptisch sind
also das könnte auch bei ihnen im
bundesland ganz schön hoch hergehen ja
das wird hoch hergehen das ist ja keine
frage aber wir können ja nicht deswegen
notwendige maßnahmen nicht machen nur
weil wir befürchten da kommt ein haar
dagegen wind sondern wir halten es
einfach für erforderlich weil wir sonst
aus dieser pandemie einfach nicht
rauskommen und
fortwährend freiheitsrechte beschränken
müssen das hat schwere wirtschaftliche
folgen für unsere kinder wenn der
unterricht an die stattfindet noch
schlimmere folgen das alles müssen wir
doch vermeiden und am schnellsten
sichern wir unsere freiheit wenn sich
die nötigen anzahl an menschen impfen
lassen und die erfahrung zeigt dass sind
noch nicht mal bei 70% wir kommen so
nicht weiter und deswegen bin ich der
meinung kommen wir einmal eine
allgemeine impfpflicht einfach nicht
vorbei es kann eigentlich denkbar ich
weiß es juristisch wirklich gar nicht ob
so was auch dann nur auf landesebene
gemacht wird oder muss das zwangsweise
ein bundesgesetz sein dass dann im
ganzen land geld nein das muss der
bundesgesetzgeber machen dann wird er
wahrscheinlich nichts draus werden denn
die ampel zeigt wenig interesse an einer
solchen allgemeinen im fluss wird man
szenen erst mal sind wir uns schon einig
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit
der amtierenden kanzlerin dass wir eine
impfpflicht einführen für einrichtungen
wie krankenhäuser alten- und
pflegeheimen also besonders wohlhabende
gruppen das ist ja schon mal ein erster
schritt nicht dann kann man einen
weiteren schritt gehen für ein
erziehungsberechtigte nicht und dann
wird die debatte glaube ich und die
erfahrung mit den debatten vielleicht
auch weiter dazu führen dass man
einsieht dass wir damit freiheit auf
mittlere sicht schützen wir kommen so am
schnellsten aus der pandemie raus und
gewinn dann unsere freiheit am
schnellsten auch alle wieder
und vor allem wir verhindern dass viele
leute sehr schwer krank werden oder gar
sterben müssen und das ist doch ein
schweres gewicht in der debatte sagt
baden-württembergs ministerpräsident
winfried kretschmann ich danke fürs
gespräch wieder schön
dass inter wir haben wir aufgezeichnet
der ball rauscht delta weiter durch
schulen und kitas schulschließungen soll
es ja auf keinen fall wieder geben
tatsächlich gibt es sie aber vielerorts
indirekt weil klassen und kitagruppen in
quarantäne müssen oder sogar ganze
schulen wegen großer ausbrüche schließen
dazu dürfte beitragen dass in einer
ganzen reihe bundesländern die masken
pflicht in schulen weiterhin abgeschafft
bleibt trotz der hohen instanzen unter
den kindern micro albrecht berichtet
über schulalltag aus brandenburg
jahrhundert ist kleine lücken im
einmaleins sind kein problem die können
die drittklässler an der grundschule in
spreenhagen schnell schließen glauben
ihre lehrer vor allem wenn die schüler
gemeinsam in der schule lernen können
das präsenzunterricht das beste für
schüler ist darin besteht ohnehin große
einigkeit sorgen bereitet den lehrern er
ihr verhalten es gebe mehr streit und
aggressionen stillsitzen und
konzentrieren sei schwierig geworden das
soziale miteinander ist ein größeres
problem eine größere baustelle und da
versuchen wir halt hier gegenzusteuern
lockdown isolation und homeschooling
haben spuren hinterlassen das sehen auch
psychologen und plädieren deswegen für
das offenhalten der schulen als weg aus
der krise es gab es viele im
angststörungen
essstörungen und depressionen die
zugenommen haben und was eben auch noch
eine rolle spielt in dem ganzen ist eben
dass eine angst im raum steht gerade
kinder und jugendlichen dass das eben
nie endet zurück so viel normalität und
miteinander wie möglich das versuchen
sie auch an der grundschule in
spreenhagen und so war das motto der
vergangenen projektwoche gemeinsame
aktivitäten statt einmaleins das kam gut
an ich hab halt gelernt
wir mehr in unserer klasse halten
händler sprechen müssen die nächsten
aktivitäten sind bereits geplant doch
das geht wohl nur weil diese schule mit
bislang nur einem corona fall in der
vierten welle offenbar eine glückliche
ausnahme ist die inzidenz bei den meist
ungeimpften jungen schülern in
brandenburg liegt nämlich mittlerweile
bei
1.500 in einem landkreis sogar bei knapp
4000 kein wunder meinen elternverbände
denn die schulen seien schlicht nicht
sicher gemacht wurden noch immer gebe es
zu schlechte technische ausstattung zu
wenig luftfilter die politik habe
abermals versagt wenn ich mir das
agieren der letzten wochen und monate so
anschaue muss man ganz einfach sagen ja
es ist wirklich planlos haltlos und eine
durchseuchung wird einfach durch
nichtstun in kauf genommen aber dann
muss man einem dem punkt auch so ehrlich
sein und sagen leute wir haben keinen
plan es passiert jetzt einfach richtet
euch darauf ein dass kinder meist nicht
schwer an corona erkranken dürfte für
diejenigen die es dann doch erwischt
kaum tröstlich sein und so stehen
politik schulen und eltern nun gemeinsam
vor dem dilemma was wiegt mehr das
grundrecht auf bildung oder das
grundrecht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit
mehr hintergründe zum gesamten thema
corona finden sie online auf zdf heute
unter anderem experten erklärungen dazu
warum ungeimpfte sich nicht nur selbst
leichter anstecken sondern auch für
andere ansteckende sind und jetzt macht
er erst einmal gute lage weiter die
nachrichten
in den niederlanden und in belgien
planen regierungen und polizei
vorkehrungen gegen eine weitere
ausbreitung der gewalt bei protesten
gegen die korona maßnahmen es sei eine
reine gewalt explosion unter dem
deckmantel von demonstrationen gewesen
so verurteilte der niederländische
regierungschef rückte die
ausschreitungen den dritten abend in
folge zogen vor gegen junge leute durch
die städte und randalierten wie hier in
brüssel mehrere menschen wurden verletzt
insgesamt wurden bei den ausschreitungen
in belgien 100 menschen festgenommen
die bundesregierung hat sich erneut
gegen die aufnahme der an der polnisch
spieler russischen grenze festsitzenden
migranten ausgesprochen
regierungssprecher seibert sagte dies
sei keine für deutschland oder die eu
akzeptable lösung viele der menschen
wurden zwischenzeitlich in
notunterkünften untergebracht nach
angaben des polnischen grenzschutzes
haben in der nacht erneut hunderte
migranten vergeblich versucht illegal
die grenze zur eu zu überwinden laut
polnischen behörden sollen sie dabei von
belarussischen soldaten unterstützt
worden sein dass
deutsche rettungsschiff swatch 4 wartet
der zeit vor der süditalienischen küste
mit mehr als 480 aus seenot geretteten
migranten an bord auf die zuweisung
eines europäischen hafens laut der
privaten organisation seien die menschen
bei insgesamt sieben einsätzen seit ende
vergangener woche von seeuntüchtigen
booten gerettet worden zuletzt 107 aus
einem überfüllten holzboot nach angaben
von sea watch ist darunter auch ein
neugeborenes
im us bundesstaat wisconsin sind bei
einem vorweihnachtlichen straßenumzug
fünf menschen getötet worden mehr als 40
wurden verletzt als ein geländewagen in
die menge fuhr zu der parade in der us
kleinstadt war ok waren viele familien
mit kindern gekommen ein verdächtiger
wurde festgenommen er soll nach einer
möglichen straftat auf der flucht vor
der polizei gewesen sein diese teilte
mit es gebe keine hinweise auf einen
terroristischen hintergrund
bulgariens staatschef hat die
präsidentenwahl in dem ärmsten land der
eu klar gewonnen bei der stichwahl
sicherte sich der von sozialisten und
protestparteien unterstützte
reformorientierte politiker fast 67
prozent der stimmen und bleibt somit
weitere fünf jahre im amt hauptthema des
58 jährigen ist der kampf gegen die
korruption
heftige kritik an radek kommt aus den
usa im wahlkampf hatte ralf die
ukrainische halbinsel krim als russisch
bezeichnet
die cdu sucht einen neuen chef
theoretisch könnte es natürlich auch
eine chefin seien aber alle drei
kandidaten sind bekanntlich männlich
eine frau steht aber trotzdem noch als
elefanten mit im raum die frau die die
geschicke der partei so lange prägte
nach dem verhältnis zu ihr werden die
potenziellen nachfolger medial sortiert
friedrich merz der anti merkel helge
braun der merkel statthalter und norbert
röttgen früher mal team merkel und
später kühlte das verhältnis ab die
kandidatenkür wird diesmal mit
publikumsbeteiligung stattfinden denn am
ende sollen die rund 400.000 cdu
mitglieder entscheiden für die cdu ein
ungewohntes verfahren heute begann das
offizielle casting daher passen
berichtet
nun also staffel 3 der reihe wo es oft
christdemokratie zum start heute eine
fragerunde für mitglieder mit einem der
schon bei den ersten zwei staffeln dabei
war
versucht rein
ja es hat etwas schon etwas irrationales
wenn sie so wollen auf der anderen seite
wissen sie diese cdu ist ein teil meines
lebens ein ganz wesentlicher teil meines
lebens ich habe mich dieser partei
innerlich immer engstens verbunden
gefühlt weil so viele ihn baten und
diesmal die mitglieder entscheiden habe
er nicht nein sagen können wie schon
zuletzt betonte merz am abend
sozialpolitisches es war aber auch der
märz zu hören der bis heute sehnsucht
figur jener ist die angela merkels
migrationspolitik zu 15 als fehler an
sehen es gibt hier keinen unbegrenzten
zuzug in die europäische union wir
brauchen allerdings auch und da ist
europa noch im rückstand wir brauchen in
dieser europäischen union auch ein
einheitliches regelwerk für einwanderung
für asylbewerber für flüchtlinge und wir
müssen dann auch uns über verteilungs
quoten unterhalten es kann nicht sein
dass alle flüchtlinge der welt alle nach
deutschland wollen und insofern habe ich
da eine klare position am nachmittag
auftritt team braun dennoch
kanzleramtsminister ist seit jahren so
etwas wie der wichtigste
vollstreckungsbeamte merkels politik
dass ausgerechnet er für einen
programmatischen neuanfang stehen will
erstaunte vor allem all jene in der
partei die ihre cdu als entkernt ansehen
am ende der ära merkel sieht keinen
widerspruch unserem privileg mit ihr
zusammenzuarbeiten da kann man von ihr
sehr sehr sehr viel lernen aber
die nächsten jahre geht es jetzt nicht
um die frage guten regierens sondern die
cdu geht in die opposition
und da habe ich eine andere
sozialisation als angela merkel ich bin
der hessischen cdu groß geworden und
diese 18 fast 18 jahre als
kreisvorsitzender haben mich sehr sehr
geprägt es komme nun darauf an frei von
koalitions zwängen cdu pur anzubieten
eine klare abgrenzung zur ampel dass
dieses neue profi gleichwohl eine starke
soziale note haben soll macht er auch
sie deutlich sera bühler und für armin
laschet in nrw staatssekretärin für
integration
sie soll unter brown generalsekretären
werden ich bin kind einer
arbeiterfamilie
mein vater war als sogenannter
gastarbeiter bergmann und lange jahre
alleinverdiener ist meine mutter sich
irgendwann entschieden hat putzen zu
gehen und auch ich habe mich vor dem
studium erstmal für eine ausbildung zur
hotelfachfrau entschieden ich weiß also
aus eigener erfahrung sehr wohl was es
heißt hart zu arbeiten
ebenfalls im team nadine schön
fraktionsvize mit schwerpunkt digitale
erneuerung die sie nicht nur fürs land
fordert mir ist wichtig dass das thema
in unserer partei raum und platz bekommt
digital fisch präsentiert sich der
dritte kandidat im webvideo wie madsen
braun verspricht auch norbert röttgen
eine modernere weiblichere mitmach
partei und wer will kann kleine spitzen
gegen die wettbewerber hören ich bin
überzeugt wir brauchen aufbruch und
erneuerung als cdu es reicht nicht
stehen zu bleiben schon gar nicht zurück
zu gehen es gibt nur eine richtung für
uns und zwar nach vorne er und braun
stellen sich mittwoch beziehungsweise
donnerstag den fragen der mitglieder
ihre jury die bis spätestens mitte
januar entscheiden wird wird diesmal
gewinnt beim christdemokratischen
casting
und jetzt nochmal bundesland mit dem
blick auf die wirtschaft da und an den
finanzmärkten war die inflationsprognose
der bundesbank zu diesem wochenauftakt
das thema auf knapp sechs prozent könnte
die inflation demnach in diesem monat
ansteigen von jetzt 4,6 prozent frank
bethmann wie sieht denn die bundesbank
die weitere inflationsentwicklung
naja ab januar erwartet die bundesbank
dass der preisdruck spürbar zurückgehen
werde aber sie kommen zugleich zu der
einschätzung dass noch länger
inflationsraten von deutlich über drei
prozent drohten und in diesem
zusammenhang ist ihr bereits jetzt ein
dorn im auge dass die mögliche neue
bundesregierung den mindestlohn auf 12
euro erhöhen wolle die ist hätte
ausstrahlungseffekte auf die darüber
liegenden lohngruppen sagen die
deutschen währungshüter ihre sorge dass
sich da eine spirale aus steigenden
preisen und steigenden löhnen dauerhaft
hochschaukeln insgesamt mahnende worte
die man zuletzt in dieser form von der
europäischen zentralbank nicht gehört
hat und in dem zusammenhang ist ja auch
wichtig dass in den usa der raum paul
der chef der notenbank in seinem amt
bestätigt wurde denn das hat ja auch
auswirkungen auf die preise hierzulande
ja unmittelbar erklommen erstmal die
amerikanischen aktienindizes neue
allzeithochs nachdem das vorhin bekannt
wurde also dort sofortige preis
auswirkungen für die verbraucherpreise
die sie meinen dürfte das über kurz oder
lang auch von bedeutung sein denn paul
steht dafür dass die fed die politik des
billigen geldes straffen wird man
rechnet damit dass es im kommenden jahr
eine erste zinserhöhung geben werde um
die teuerung damit daneben einzufangen
in den usa wohl gemerkt hier in europa
ist man noch nicht soweit
leitzinsanhebungen derzeit hier noch
überhaupt kein thema
vielen dank frank bethmann
der internationale sport bleibt in sorge
um die zwischenzeitlich verschwundene
tennisspielerin rang zwei
präsident bach wurde für sein gestriges
telefonat mit der chinesin heftig
kritisiert der ioc mache sich
mitschuldig an der böswilligen
chinesischen propaganda zudem das
telefonat gewährleiste weder ihre
sicherheit noch ihr wohlergehen 2 hatte
anfang november einem chinesischen
politiker sexuell übergriffig kite
vorgeworfen und war daraufhin aus der
öffentlichkeit verschwunden laut ioc
geht es um zwei gut der ioc habe ihre
unterstützung angeboten
corona macht auch
fußball-bundesligisten sorgen in dieser
champions league woche muss zum beispiel
bayern münchen trainer nagelsmann auf
acht spieler verzichten 5 sind in corona
quarantäne der fc bayern ist bereits
qualifiziert für das achtelfinale
trotzdem will die rumpfmannschaft morgen
gegen dynamo kiew auch die bundesliga
niederlage zuletzt gegen augsburg wieder
eine berühmtheit zu verkaufen ist für
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler eine
herausforderung vor allem wenn die
verkörperte personen den zeitgenossen
noch in lebhafter erinnerung ist wenn es
sich dann aber auch noch um einen
superstar der musikwelt handelt einen
menschen mit unvergleichlicher stimme
bis das eine wirklich schwere aufgabe
jennifer hudson hat sie nach ansicht der
filmkritik glänzend gelöst und sie hatte
dafür quasi himmlischen segen denn lisa
franklin höchst selbst hatte vor ihrem
tod bestimmt das hatten sie auf der
leinwand verkörpern sollte am donnerstag
kommt respekt bei uns in die kinos nadja
nasa hat den 95 angesehen und vor allem
auch angehört
[Musik]
jennifer hudson als evita franklin eine
der größten stimmen des showbusiness
sind die songs der queen of soul
dass jennifer hudson sie spielen soll
ein wunsch von rita franklin persönlich
kurz vor ihrem tod 2008 10
es sei es ist so aufregend und eine ehre
und ein traum dass arita franklin mich
ausgewählt hat um ihre geschichte zu
erzählen
aber gleichzeitig ist es auch wirklich
beängstigend und hat den druck auf mich
noch einmal erhöht nicht dass ich davon
nicht schon genug gehabt hätte
der film erzählt von arias aufstieg zum
globalen superstar und ihrem harten
kampf um mehr selbstbestimmung
eine weltkarriere die in den 50er jahren
in der gemeinde ihres vaters beginnt du
bist doch besonderes talent sie nämlich
in dem einflussreichen baptistenprediger
ciel franklin gespielt von forest
whitaker
frühwirth ihre ausnahme stimme erkannt
[Musik]
sie nimmt mit 14 ihre erste platte auf
heiratet mit 19 ihr mann tat wird ihr
manager will über sie und ihre karriere
bestimmen wir wollen originalsongs
du kannst reden oder nicht nur singen
der film respekt bleibt nah an der
wahren geschichte arriva franklins ein
leben voller erfolge aber auch
überschattet von missbrauch depressionen
und privaten rückschlägen
gleichzeitig wird sie zur stimme der
schwarzen bürgerrechtsbewegung singt für
martin luther king und gegen
unterdrückung der song respekt wird zu
ihrer hymne
[Musik]
sie ist ein wichtiger teil des kampfes
um bürgerrechte sie tragen zu den
menschen durch wurde zu ihrer stimme
gegen jede form von ungerechtigkeit und
das hat sie so bedeutend gemacht bis
heute
wir müssen den frieden stören wenn man
uns kein frieden gewährten der film ist
eine bewegende verbeugung vor einer
großen kämpferin
für frauen und minderheitenrechte und
für ihr eigenes glück getragen von der
großartigen stimme von jennifer hudson
[Musik]
mit kino geht es gleich auch weiter mit
den protonen flüssen im zdf montagskino
und um 23 45 ist hier wieder zeit für
unser heute-journal update mit
christopher wehrmann heute morgen wieder
bis dahin
[Musik]
guten abend die unwetter verschnaufpause
am mittelmeer war wirklich nur kurz
jetzt kommt wir ein tieferen tiefs das
bringt jetzt erst mal schnee nach
spanien und dann unwetter am zentralen
mittelmeer und es bringt auch zu uns in
deutschland schnee aber erst am ende der
woche aktuell beschäftigen uns hier eher
die keys xeno filius und das -hoch
walpurga das bedeutet für uns eher
ruhiges spätherbst wetter mit nur ganz
wenig regen dieser wenige regen fällt
heute nacht an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee sonst ist es zum teil stärker
bewölkt aber auch mal sternen klar an
den alpen fällt noch etwas regen oder
auch schneeregen das bildet sich zum
teil nebel wenn es klar ist wird es sehr
frostig die temperaturen sacken auf
minus drei bis minus fünf grad das
wasser hält dagegen wärmer deswegen
liegen die tiefstwerte an den küsten von
ost und nordsee bei 6 bis 3 grad in
norddeutschland sind das morgen meist so
acht bis zehn grad meist bleibt es bei
zwei bis sieben grad aber kälter und in
norddeutschland wird das morgen ein eher
trüber tag mit etwas nieselregen
vielleicht an den küsten auch mal etwas
sonnenschein richtig strahlenden
sonnenschein werden sie aber morgen wohl
nur in süddeutschland sehen wenn sich da
nicht nebel und hochnebel zäh halten das
kann aber durchaus passieren mittwoch in
der donnerstag erinnert sich an unserem
wetter noch wenig aber dann am freitag
da wird es dann aus den alpen
herausschneiden und wie sie hier am
trend für münchen sehen können liegen
dann die höchsttemperatur und tagsüber
zum teil über null grad ganz klar dass
es dann eher schneit als regnet guten
abend